Guten Tag.
Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Emre Göchtas. Ich bin der zuständige Arzt für Sie.
Bevor wir anfangen, lassen Sie mich bitte zuerst Ihre personische Daten notieren.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid oder fragen Sie nach, okay?
Ja, einfach danken.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Hans Zimmermann.
Mit Dopplerm, ja.
Mit Dopplerm, Dopplerm, ja.
Gut. Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Zimmermann?
Ich bin 50 Jahre alt.
Verraten Sie mir bitte Ihr Geburtstatement?
2. April 1971.
71.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,85 m groß.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich habe abgenommen, also jetzt sehe ich ungefähr so 68 kg.
68.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe drei Kinder, ja.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich arbeite in der IT-Branche.
IT-Branche.
Okay.
Herr Zimmermann, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Herr Doktor, ich komme mit verschiedenen Problemen zu Ihnen.
Das geht schon eine ganze Weile.
Aber heute Morgen habe ich jetzt erstmal so Herzrasen gehabt.
Und bin zum Hausarzt gegangen.
Und der hat dann EKG gemacht und gesagt, ich muss ins Krankenhaus.
Ich hätte Vorhofflimmen.
Das war der Grund.
Aber meine Beschwerden gehen schon einige Wochen.
Das dauert sich schon an.
Und jetzt bin ich wegen diesem Herzrasen gekommen.
Okay.
Wann waren Sie beim Hausarzt?
Heute Morgen.
Okay.
Und seit einigen Wochen haben Sie Herzrasen?
Nein, das Herzrasen ist neu seit heute Morgen.
Aber ich habe andere Probleme seit Wochen schon belasten.
Was war denn?
Ich habe erstens Gewicht abgenommen,
letzten Monaten.
Ich bin insgesamt nicht wie früher.
Ich bin unruhig.
Ich bin gereizt.
Ich bin sehr nervös.
Ich kann nicht mehr schlafen.
Also kann nachts eigentlich kaum mehr als 1-2 Stunden am Stück schlafen.
Ich habe Schweißausbrüche.
Ich bin nicht psychisch überlastet.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es von der Arbeit kommt.
Ich habe abgenommen, obwohl ich eigentlich sehr guten Appetit habe.
Ich esse sehr viel.
Aber ich habe trotzdem mit Gewicht abgenommen.
Ungefähr fast 8-9 Kilo.
Insgesamt ist mein Zustand nicht gut seit ein, 2 Monaten.
Okay, verstehe.
Haben Sie Herzrasen?
Das ist neu.
Deswegen komme ich jetzt zu Ihnen.
Haben Sie Erbrochen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Fieber gemerkt?
Nein, kann ich nicht sagen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Ich habe häufiger Stuhlgang.
Der Stuhl ist manchmal auch dünner als sonst.
Ich habe auch immer die Probleme,
aber ich habe auch immer die Probleme.
Es ist kein Durchfall, aber es ist manchmal sehr brei.
Früher habe ich nur alle 2 Tage Stuhlgang gehabt.
Jetzt habe ich dann jeden Tag.
Manchmal sogar 2 Mal pro Tag.
Obwohl die Appetit nicht gut ist.
Appetit ist sehr gut.
Ja, genau.
Entschuldigung.
Wie war die Farbe und Stuhlgang?
Normale.
Haben Sie Atemnot oder Brustschmerzen?
Kann ich so nicht sagen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Atemfrequenz?
Da fragen Sie etwas.
Ich habe nicht darauf geachtet.
Noch haben Sie
Veränderungen in der letzten Zeit aufgefallen?
Mein Hals ist etwas dicker geworden.
Ich habe auch hier seitlich so Lymphknoten.
Keine Halsschmerzen.
Ich habe keine Halsschmerzen.
Das ist mir aufgefallen.
Haben Sie Schluckbeschwerde beim Essen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Heiserkeit?
Ich habe etwas hinzufügen.
Die aktuelle Beschwärde.
Wir haben viele aktuelle Beschwärde.
Ne, das möchte ich nicht sagen.
Zittern.
Ich habe keine Zittern,
ich habe die Ев awareness curve
ist mal festgestellt worden. Dann habe ich so Reflux, habe ich mal gehabt, bin dann mal
indiskupiert worden und sonst eine Operation, hatte ich mal eine Meniscus-Operation, also
eine Sportverletzung, einen rechten Knie, sonst habe ich keine anderen Krankheiten bisher gehabt.
Okay, seit wann haben Sie diese Erkrankungen, Gallensteine und Reflux-Operation?
Seit ungefähr einem Jahr habe ich mit der Haushaltsaufgabe so Tablette aufgeschrieben,
die ich jetzt jeden Tag einnehme, damit der Gallenstein sich auflösen kann.
Okay, welche Tabletten nehmen Sie?
Also Osofalk, das ist für die Gallensteine, nehme ich morgen abends und dann nehme
mich für den Reflux-Pantropazol.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie irgendwelche wesentliche Erkrankungen,
die ich wissen sollte, wie ein Bluthochdruck oder Diabetes?
Ja, also meine Mutter hat Diabetes und hat auch COPD, Bluthochdruck.
Mein Vater hat Herz-Rhythmusstörung gehabt, er hat auch einen Herzschrittmacher bekommen,
ansonsten kann ich mich jetzt nicht an andere Krankheiten erinnern.
Okay, der Vater hat Herzschrittmacher und Rhythmusstörungen, ja?
Ja, wie Rhythmus ist gesagt worden, hat damals einen Herzschrittmacher bekommen, ja.
Gut, wir müssen ja feinern, viel besser.
Schlafen Sie gut, haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
Wie gesagt, habe ich ja schon gesagt, ich kann nicht gut schlafen.
Ich schlafe maximal ein bis zwei Stunden am Stück, mache oft auf, kann nicht einschlafen.
Schlafen ist schlecht.
Okay, wegen der Beschwerden, ja?
Ich weiß nicht, ich denke, dass ich insgesamt aufgeregt und nervös bin
und das ist auch nachts so, glaube ich, und deswegen kann ich nicht schlafen.
Okay, gibt es etwas, was Sie sie nicht belastet?
Ja, ich habe auch auf der Arbeit viel zu tun, das ist schon ein stressiger Beruf, den ich habe,
aber man hat andere Sachen, kann ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Okay, Hause Ösefreik und Antoprasol, nehmen Sie irgendwelche Regeln,
müssen die Medikamente ein oder beide darf?
Nein, das sind die Medikamente, die ich nehme, mehr nehme ich nicht.
Okay, schlafen Sie?
Nein, ich habe mal geraucht, aber nur ganz kurz, so ein, zwei Jahre,
als ich so 18, 19 war, dann habe ich aufgehört.
Wie lange haben Sie geraucht?
Ein oder zwei Jahre, nicht lange.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Selten, also einmal im Monat vielleicht.
Einmal im Monat, okay.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen Allergien bekannt?
Man hat nicht verdacht, dass ich so eine Penizidienallergie hatte,
da habe ich mal Antibiotika gereagiert, vor langer Zeit.
Wie äußert sich diese Allergien?
Da habe ich Hautausschlag bekommen, den ganzen Körper.
Das ist ein Hautausschlag, okay.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie sind in der letzten Zeit unrieg, gereizt und sehr nervös.
Ich möchte auch fragen, ob Sie ein Konzentrationstürmung haben.
Ja, kann man schon sagen.
Ich habe schon Schwierigkeiten, mich als Normal zu konzentrieren.
Also ist nicht wie früher.
Ich verstehe.
Okay, meineseits habe ich die wichtigsten Fragen gestellt.
Müssten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen?
Nein, die wichtigsten Sachen haben Sie aufgeschrieben, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, es ist eine Konzentration.
Okay, jetzt glaube ich, Sie möchten die Diagnose wissen.
Aber jetzt kann ich Ihnen nicht genau sagen,
was Sie haben.
Erst mal werden wir die körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Danach möchte ich ein paar diagnostische,
weitere diagnostische machen,
damit wir die richtige Diagnose stellen können.
Ja.
Ich würde Ihnen Blut abnehmen
und ein Halsultraschall durchführen,
weil ich die Halsschwellungen kontrollieren möchte.
Und ja, erst mal diese Untersuchung ist genug.
Dann je nach den Ergebnisse besprechen wir nochmal,
wie es weitergeht.
Machen Sie auch ein CT?
Was meinen Sie, brauche ich für Untersuchungen?
CT? Ja.
Erst mal möchte ich die Ultraschallergebnisse anschauen.
Danach können wir eine CT-Untersuchung veranlassen.
Ja.
Vielen Dank, Herr Doktor.
Bitte nehmen Sie Platz im Wartesma.
Ich komme Ihnen gleich.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Es gibt Kommentare, Fragen von den Zuhörern.
Erklagen Sie die Weime gut?
Nein, es ist mir heiß.
Ich muss gleich mein Hemd ausziehen, wenn es zu heiß ist.
Ist Ihr Haut feucht?
Ja, es spitzt sich dann ein bisschen.
Was gibt es noch für Fragen?
Ich habe es wichtig gefragt.
Was ich noch gefragt hätte, wäre,
ob Sie Seestörungen haben.
Dann habe ich nicht verloren.
Wenn wir keine weiteren Kommentare haben,
gehen wir zur Oberarztvorstellung.
Eine Minute, bitte.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patient vorstellen.
Haben Sie gut Zeit?
Bitte schön.
Ich möchte Sie ein paar Mal sagen,
dass ich das nicht so gut bin.
Es geht um Hans Zimmermann,
er ist 50 Jahre alt.
Er hat 3 Kinder,
68 kg und 185 cm groß.
Er klagt über Tashukadi
seit heute Morgen.
Er war beim Hausarzt.
Er hat bei ihm eine EKG gemacht.
Ein Vorhoff,
eine atrielle Fibrillation,
wurde bei ihm festgestellt.
Er ist uns gekommen.
Er ist zu uns gekommen.
Er ist nicht zu uns gekommen.
Er ist der oleh,
Er ist 2 Monaten,
er hat 9 kg abgenommen.
Obwohl sein Apetit gut ist.
Und er auch Conventionstörung.
Hyperhydrosinopthrytone.
Er describe keine richtige Diarete
richtige Diare, aber der Stuhlgang ist dünn und er hat seit einigen Wochen eine Halsschwellung
gehabt.
Er ist in der letzten Zeit aufgefallen und er klagt auch über Tremor seit einigen Wochen.
Und in der Vorerkrankungen liegt Colelitiasis seit einigen Jahren und Gastroesophageale
Reflexkrankheiten seit einigen Jahren.
Und in der Familienanamnese liegt mutterlicherseits Pace Maker und Arithmie und vaterlicherseits
Diabetes Militus, COPD und Arteriella Hipertunifor.
Und er nimmt regelmäßig Ösefaltabletten morgens abends und Pantroprasol morgens ein.
Er ist allergisch gegen Penicillin und äußert sich mit Hautausschlag.
Nach den bisherigen Angaben gehe ich von Hyperthreose aus.
Dafür sprechen die genannten Sempromen wie Tashikadi und Konzentrationsstörung und
Gewichtverlust und die Hyperhydrosenotone und die Halsschwellungen.
Aber die pharaonziale Diagnostik kommt zum Beispiel ein Truidkarzinom im Betracht,
weil dafür sprechen die Gewichtverlust auch.
Habt man bei Hyperthreose ohne Karzinom auch Gewichtsverlust?
Für Hyperthreose sprechen auch Gewichtsverlust auch.
Also muss kein Karzinom sein, gell?
Ja genau.
Okay.
Ich würde erstmal diesen Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Danach würde ich auch einen Blut abnehmen.
Im Blut kontrolliere ich Friedte 4 und T3 und TCA-Werte.
Was erwartet ihr da?
Ja, wenn der Patient ein primäres Hyperthreose hat und TCA-Werte kann niedrig sein
und Friedte 3 und T4-Werte erhöht.
Ich möchte auch die Entzündungparameter kontrollieren, ob der Patient ein Entzündung an der Truid hat.
Ja, okay.
Danach würde ich auch eine Ultraschall durchführen, ob der Patient eine Nodulus hat oder nicht.
Richtig.
Danach ein CT ist eine gute Option.
Ja, wieso?
Wie machen Sie das CT?
Mit Kontrastmitteln.
Sicher?
Nein.
Warum?
Weil Kontrastmitteln aus IOT besteht.
Deswegen ist das gefährlich für die hyperthreuse Schock.
Das ist das erste Problem, damit können Sie eine tyriotoxische Krise auslösen.
Was ist das zweite Problem?
Wenn Sie mal andere Diagnose denken, die Sie gesagt haben, Differenzialdiagnose.
Tritkarsen, dann meinen Sie.
Was ist da das Problem?
Wenn Sie CT mit Kontrastmitteln machen?
Ich weiß nicht.
Dann machen Sie die Therapie kaputt.
Dann können Sie keine Radiotherapie mehr machen.
Weil dann das ganze Jodendärschildtröse drin ist, dann können Sie nicht mehr radioaktiv machen.
Ach so, ja, genau.
Das wäre ein Problem.
Kein CT, wenn dann CT ohne Kontrastmittel, aber das ist nicht so gut für die Ausbildung.
Dann würde ich lieber ein MRT machen, wenn Sie unbedingt eine Person brauchen.
Oder CT ohne Kontrastmittel. Wichtig.
Weil ich gedacht auf schildtrösen Krankheiten oder Katzenohmen.
CT immer ohne Kontrastmittel.
Nein.
Was machen Sie noch?
Hat sich jemand reingeschrieben, sehe ich gerade?
Ja, Zintigraphie.
Was sehen Sie bei der Zintigraphie?
Wo nachschauen Sie da?
Hyperaktive Nodule.
Wenn der Patient eine hyperaktive Nodule hat, können wir mit Zintigraphie bestätigen, ob der Patient eine hyperaktive oder hyperaktive Nodule.
Okay.
Und wir können auch die Hyperfunktion der schildtrösen überpüren.
Genau, ob Sie eine Autonomie haben, zum Beispiel.
Ja.
Okay, gut.
Okay.
Kennen Sie eine Krankheit, die die Hypertereose als Hauptsympher hat?
Hashimoto.
Hashimoto macht meistens dann eher eine Hypertereose. Am Anfang kann man es sein.
Gravis, ja.
Genau. Was ist Gravis?
Gravis.
Gravis, Morbes, Basado.
Gravis ist im Deutschland nicht bekannt.
Gravis gibt es nicht in Deutschland. Morbes, Basado.
Kennen Sie die Merseburger Trias?
Das sind drei Symptome, die bei Morbes, Basado immer vorkommen.
Nein, drei Symptome.
Ja, Merseburger Trias heißt die. Ich weiß nicht, warum.
Also, gab es einen Arzt, der glaube ich in Merseburger war oder wie auch immer.
Strumer, Exo-Authalmus und Tachikadi. Ja, hat schon jemand reingeschrieben.
Ja, genau.
Manchmal bei Morbes, Basado vorhanden.
Deswegen habe ich auch gefragt, ob der Patient See-Störungen hat.
Wenn Exo-Authalmus da ist, kommen die manchmal Probleme beim Sehen oder
Beschwerden mit den Augen.
Ja.
Gut. Okay.
Aber Sie haben noch als Differenzialdiagnosant Schilddrüsen Katzenorm,
warum ist das richtig?
Oder warum haben Sie das gesagt?
Ich habe gedacht, der Patient, der es ist,
der hat eine Schilddrüsen-Katzenorm.
Wie haben Sie das gesagt?
Ich habe gedacht, der Patient ein Gewichtverlust hat.
Deswegen unter einer Halsschwellung.
Deswegen habe ich gedacht, ja, das ist bestimmt eine Hypertreose.
Aber Schild-Inch-Schilddrüsen, diese Symptome,
sprechen dagegen.
Ich meine, eine Thruid-Katzenorm kann mit einem Klinik von
Hypertreose kommen.
Ja.
Richtig.
Alles, was Sie gesagt haben, ist bei Hypertreose auch
möglich, also Gewichtsverlust.
Und Halsschwellung, Stromer, ist bei Hypertreose oft.
Ist nicht spezifisch für Katzenorm.
Aber, was der Patient genannt hat,
haben Sie auch noch mal gesagt,
da machen Sie Ultrascher, er hat ja Lymphknoten bemerkt.
Lymphknoten gibt es bei Hypertreose normalerweise nicht,
bei normaler Hypertreose, bei Basidorf eigentlich auch nicht.
Deswegen, Lymphknoten, wenn die geschwollen sind,
dann ist da der hochgradige Verdacht,
dass da auch ein Schilddrüsen-Katzenorm dahinter stecken kann.
Das war die wichtige Information aus der Anase,
die Sie dafür nehmen für das Schilddrüsen-Katzenorm.
Der Patient hatte in der Tat jetzt
eine Hypertreose bei Schilddrüsen-Katzenorm.
Kennen Sie die verschiedenen Schilddrüsen-Katzenormen?
Die verschiedenen, wissen Sie das zufällig?
Wissen Sie nicht, wissen Sie?
Ja, ich weiß nicht genau.
Es gibt die follikulären und populären
Schilddrüsen-Katzenorme.
Sie können oft, wie gesagt,
eine Schilddrüse über Funktion machen.
Und dann gibt es noch das Mediuläre
oder eine klassische Schilddrüsen-Katzenorm.
Das macht in der Regel keine Hypertreose.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie nehmen Blut ab.
Kennen Sie einen Wert, den Sie bei Verdacht
auf Schilddrüsen-Katzenormen bestimmen können?
Gut völlig, wissen Sie nicht, wissen Sie?
Im Blut, ein Tumormarker.
Tumormarker, ja.
Vollikulär Schilddrüsen-Katzenorme
ist oft das Thürioglobulin.
Bei Mediulären-Schilddrüsen-Katzenorm
gibt es mal Kaltzytonin als Marker manchmal.
Gut, was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Wenn das Schilddrüsen-Katzenorm ist?
Erst mal, wir machen ein Radioterapie
für diese Patienten.
Erst mal machen wir die Diagnose.
Erst Diagnose stellen, machen Sie mit Biopsy meistens.
Genau.
Dann haben Sie nachgewiesen, ein Schilddrüsen-Katzenorm,
eine vollikuläres Schilddrüsen-Katzenorm.
Was machen Sie dann?
Ein Chemotherapie.
Wenn Staging?
Ja, hat Lymphknoten, lokal aber keine sonstigen Probleme.
Dann können wir mit chirurgischen Operativen behandeln?
Ja, okay.
Wenn wir nicht operativ behandeln,
dann können wir ein Chemotherapie und Radioterapie durchschwören.
Man macht eine Regel an Radioterapie.
Aber da muss man vorher gucken,
dass man die Schilddrüse vermutlich operativ entfernt.
Sonst gibt es eine starke Entzündung durch die Radioterapie.
Warum macht man eine Radioterapie?
Für die Schilddrüsen-Katzenorm?
Nein.
Wir machen die Gewebe ab.
Wir machen erst mal Hypothriose für diese Patienten.
Mit Radioterapie.
Dann geben wir den Patienten Hormon-Terapie,
wie Ertragoxin.
Dann können wir die Gewebe aktivieren.
Man geht den Patienten als künstliches TSH,
damit die Radioterapie aufnehmen soll.
Damit die Radioterapie in die bösen Zellen reingeht.
Sie machen es kaputt.
Sie haben auch versteckte andere Zellen.
Sie haben auch medizinsale Zellen.
Sie haben gesagt,
bevor Sie die Operation oder die Radioterapie machen können,
müssen Sie die Patienten vorbehandeln.
Was ist die Therapie bei einer Hypothriose?
Wie behandelt man die?
Normalerweise.
Für die Atrelle-Fibrillation geben wir ein Betoblocker.
Das zum Beispiel.
Diese Patienten haben hohe Trüb-Werte.
Erst mal müssen wir diese Werte erneidrigen.
Wie machen Sie das?
Im Hypothriose machen wir ein Radioterapie?
Oder gibt es Medikamentebehandlungen?
Medikamentebüsen sind sogar die Thyrostatiker.
Medikamentebüsen sind die Synthese von T3 und T4-Hemmen.
Die Ausschüttung.
Kennen Sie ein Beispiel dafür?
Ein Medikament ist nicht so wichtig.
Ein Profizil?
Ja, also Cabimazol oder Propyltioberziel.
Propizil ist Handelsname.
In Deutschland werden meistens Tiermazol und Cabimazol verwendet.
Das sind die beiden häufigsten.
Aber es ist Spezialisten-Endokynologie.
Warum sind Sie nicht unbedingt?
Okay, haben wir sehr viel gefragt über die Schilddröse.
Danke.